this is a tweet from Julio rosis Andy no
has quote tweeted it at the Hamas
celebration rally in Times Square
organized by the far-left Socialists and
Palestinian nationalists a speaker talks
about the islamist attacks that killed
hundreds of Israelis mostly civilians
the crowd cheers I uh I hope you're
ready to hear this this is It's just
awful and parag glided across sorry
early morning on Saturday October 7th
our resistance storms illegal settlement
and parag glided across Colonial
borders into the largest military Bas
around all right in this operations and
off of flood the resistance fires more
than 5,000
Rockets wait for
it do you hear that reaching T reaching
Tel Aviv okay in in in in a conflict uh
let's say you're you're in a prison
you're you're in a prison they say it's
an open air prison you're locked up and
you're like it is unjust I was put here
against my will and my parents were here
and so you decide to start bombing the
town next door with a bunch of civilians
who live nearby I I just you're not
breaking out you're not it's it's like a
Sally out kind of if you're in a if
you're in a Siege situation and you're
the one that's under siege sometimes
they Sally out and try and cause havoc
in the enemy camp the enemy Siege camp
and then come back and and kill as much
and Destroy as much as they can that's
kind of what this was was a imagine
if they didn't kill a bunch of civilians
targeted the military only and were seen
on video clearing civilians out and
telling them to get back and then issu
issued a statement saying you know our
our issue is with the occupying force of
the Israeli government who have
oppressed and suppressed us we will take
every every effort to protect the lives
of cilian that's not what they're doing
they're outright saying in quotes they
will execute civilians to get what they
want mhm bro there is evil in this world
it's not tactically smart from their
standpoint either because now there's
justification for them being completely
wiped out yep yeah so this this video in
particular just reminds me of pavo's dog
right they say she says colonizers and
the crowd who's all raised in the west
they're all American cheer because they
know from every Public School history
lesson that the word colonization is
always bad I mean they can't see that
there might be any bias in this I mean
obviously they've chosen to go to this
so they have their own own leaning but
with this argument it's it's just I
don't I don't know I I hate that this is
something that people are going to
decide they have an opinion on all of a
sudden because of the media media slant
because really it's an area of the world
that most people don't understand well
enough to truly understand what's going
on they have signs at this protest
saying end us funding of
Israel many of the people who are
arguing that we not fund Israel it's not
a principled argument about about
America First and saving the American
people it is them secretly trying to get
Israel to be in a weakened position so
that they can start genociding people
that's it look I'm not saying that
Israelis like Palestinians I'm not
saying that at all I'm saying these
people here are referring to Hamas as
their Fighters there's another video
where they say the same thing where
these activists and palestin and there's
many there's Palestinians here outright
say that Hamas is them and they're doing
this intentionally Co Constantine kissen
made an excellent tweet I think it was
yesterday and saying you you people in
the west and he was kind of like it's
like you you've been told for so long
that they hate you for your freedom and
it's not that they hate you because you
have more power than them and if they
had more power than you they would
conquer you colonize you and turn you
into something much worse so get your
head straight and I I've been so
anti-war I put it in quotes but like for
20 years like no don't but like I can
only fathom what would happen if the
United States was taken over by
Marauders or barbarians that would rape
and kill like that would be incable we
cannot allow that to happen this is the
farle they they the Democratic
socialists of America promoted this
rally and at this rally they celebrated
the targeting of civilians okazi Cortez
is a card carrying member of the
democratic socialists of America has she
spoken up about it I don't think so
other than the squad called for a
ceasefire which is just I just look man
yes okay okay we don't want any more
fighting but you are hard pressed to be
like hey we stormed and killed a bunch
of civilians took a bunch of hostages
now ceasefire it just seems like
arrogance on their part right well we
called for it over here in America so
you guys should stop I think they
thought the Hamas perhaps thought that
uh taking the hostages would prevent any
kind of retaliation and they
miscalculated and then when the bomb
started dropping in Gaza they were like
we need to stop this right now stop
retaliation no no they're saying they're
going to they're going to execute the
civilians in in in response to now the
bombs but I think they thought that if
they took the civilians a lot of
captives then they they'd have some time
I disagree uh the Alazan Brigade sets up
rocket Depot in hospitals and schools
and residential areas on purpose to
force Israel to strike civilian targets
and then comply at they're striking
civilian targets the argument from any
of the pro Palestine side is where
should their resistance fighter set up
at all because there's no there's
there's no military bases there and
where do the people go what do we do do
we take them in as refugees into the
United States no well a lot of people
are saying expect to see you know
millions of refugees now and this is
another thing which maybe we'll touch on
you talk about an open border hundreds
of thousands of people coming across how
many of those people are like Sleeper
Cell yes it's a serious concern right
this is true of of all kinds of things U
saying you're a refugee doesn't necess
me and that that's terrible because
there are people in awful positions who
do need support and help but opening
every Border in the US because we've
decided to get involved in wars that we
are ultimately not sure how we're going
to end anyways is sort of not the
solution right we're creating more
problems for everyone all the time it's
I mean it it is one of the reasons that
you have to be so critical of the Biden
Administration which is that they they
were not uh proactive On the Border the
way they should have been and they have
also been club-footed when it comes to
International diplomacy they have not
put an American in strong position so
we're actually in a in my opinion not a
very strong position to help anyone in
any way so for for there are a lot of
reasons for this and I'm not trying to
put anyone on the spot this not a
rhetorical question it's a literal
question for you guys for what reason is
the US providing military funding to
Israel um to protect the Suez Canal it
just depends on how you're looking at it
well that's Egypt though that's a sin
Peninsula yeah but Israel's got war war
ples and Egypt's also on on our side our
side it's on the side right but Israel
is not on the sus is controlled by Egypt
um shipping maybe but well I mean they
it kind of guards the Suez it's not
obviously the Suz is in Egypt yeah it's
a it's a it's a it's yeah it's on the uh
so the Sinai Peninsula is where the Suez
is and then you have um Israel further
east of there so perhaps there's a
strategic military you know point
because it gives them the Eastern side
of the suest I supp it always was too
because the Romans would sail over there
well they would do it through Egypt but
then they would pick their boats up and
walk them across before the canal was
ever built and then put it back down and
then sail to India I mean that it
probably is the most logical reason the
control of canals is massive I mean
right now we're looking you the conflict
in Ukraine has a lot to do with the
Bosphorus uh the BOS the BOS straight
that's going through turkey that gets
from that that uh uh opens up the Black
Sea to the Mediterranean so taking
Russia's War water port in Crimea if
NATO were to acquire or the EU were to
absorb uh Ukraine would be very bad for
Russia so now Russia is trying to secure
this whole land re this whole land
bridge into Crimea because that's where
they have access to the Black Sea and
then there's other there's other points
of access they have into the Black Sea
into the Black Sea as well but this is a
major Naval base for them and then of
course you have what what maybe the Suez
obviously the Panama Canal was massively
and strategically important for us to
control and I think it was like 10 years
ago China was trying to build a
Nicaraguan Canal which is insane because
the land mass is massive whereas Panama
is very thin and then uh with the
Nicaraguan Canal they would have to
decimate this natural aquafer that
everyone got water from ultimately I
think the the the the uh program was
abandoned however but it could be it
could be that the US we hear this all
the time that Israel is our most
important Ally in the region I'm like
okay okay I guess in the sense that in
terms of the form of government and the
perception like the the the world view
yes that makes sense but what is the
actual strategic military purpose I
wonder anybody got a better idea than
the Suez I mean that's what I would say
I mean I think ultimately America thinks
of itself as historically Israel's Ally
and so it feels the need to intervene um
it's it's a question that I think
everyone should ask themselves like what
really is the Strategic purpose of
getting involved at this point uh and I
don't I honestly don't have a great
answer for it and I think a lot of
Americans will feel that way so should
we continue to you know we've already
moved uh military ships closer to Israel
we are preparing to get involved if in
in in more ways than we are are already
now um we already spent billions of
dollars on Ukraine this year I mean is
not something that we can really do
we're going into an election I wonder if
this is this strike is partly because
they know the US is fractured and and
distracted yeah speaking of distracted
Jack pic tweeted out earlier here it his
White House Stafford this from two hours
ago this is he's saying that this is
from a White House staffer uh Biden
keeps bringing up Ukraine during
briefings on Israel he's getting the two
Wars mixed up Austin Lloyd Austin
secretary uh what is Secretary of
Defense Secretary of Defense uh barely
showing up to them to them anymore the
meetings anymore uh blink and making
more decisions than anyone so you talk
about confusion within the leadership of
the United States right now
Biden Biden is
he's probably concerned about getting
caught for his business and also UK you
know we've all had concerns about
Biden's mental faculties always so it
maybe it's just you know the old age
catching up with him you you know they
had a barbecue yesterday they were at a
barbecue at the White House Biden and
his wife and a bunch of White House sta
or the day before yesterday like during
the bombs dropping in Israel Biden's
throwing a party well yeah but to be
fair dur the bomb cancel the party dur
the the war no during the bombs going
off in Sudan or or Somalia they're also
having barbecues yeah but it's Israel so
so what this this is another the problem
I have with many of the people who are
like we need to intervene in Ukraine or
you Israel's our Ally I'm like China's
running concentration camps where
they're genociding weager Muslims are we
going to are we going to go to every
single country on the planet whenever a
bomb Falls no but if your one of your
Military Allies is under attack you go
to the war room and that's where you
stay for the next 28 hours or whatever I
was on Twitter for like 12 hours
yesterday Biden can do it he should be
that's he's our Commander he's a
military commander when bombs Dro
Commander go to war room considering and
I I will I I accept this considering the
severity of the escalation yes I agree
that he should have been but it does
frustrate me that the news goes nuts
when like Ukraine goes off and I'm like
a border dispute with Russia and a
neighboring Nation why do I care why
aren't we talking about what's going on
in say these these African nations or
with the Armenians I mean we didn't we
didn't intervene with the a uh but way
back in the day there are definitely
there's always been a stance that we
pick and choose and I'm glad that you
brought up the weer Muslims because we
still sent our Olympic team we made a
big show of saying we're not going to
send any of our officials or diplomates
yet we still went with it I mean the
double standard for what we are allowed
to be outraged on humanitarian platforms
it's just ridiculous and I think
ultimately we know that this is not
based on any sort of uh bleeding heart
dedication to anything it's always about
something strategic and Powerful and in
this case we've already put ourselves in
a weak position so what are we I think
that's like I can't get past the point
of what is the purpose of this I just my
question is what what about Israel makes
people's brains stop working no question
I think it's just like what because of
religion because of Judaism they feel so
connected to the land
itself I'm not talking about people who
are Jewish or Israeli I'm talking about
right now on Twitter right now even in
our chats there are people who's brains
shut off the moment the subject of
Israel comes up they stop listening to
arguments they when it comes to Ukraine
you can have a rational conversation
about intervention Israel happens and
it's just like hyperpolarized no matter
what you say you're wrong no matter what
you say you're right it's just there
there's there's no rational thought
whatsoever it's the most annoying thing
in the world I used to have a a chat
server and um the most annoying thing in
the world was people always tried to
make Israel a subject like to talk about
it when it was not even in the news
there whatever it is there there are
places in the world right now where
there are tribal factions locking up
oppressing beating and murdering other
factions there are there there China for
instance but for some reason it's Israel
it pisses it's so annoying I'm like hey
okay let's like check out the history of
what's going on and they're like the the
the people right now the conspiracy
theory is that uh Israel knew it was
going to happen and let it happen so
they could justify flattening Gaza and
it's just like
okay
dude yeah I heard at any point everyone
is just going to choose what they want
to be the reality yeah okay there are
videos of thing happening if you're
going to make the assumptions that
Israel knew there's a report saying
Egypt warned warned them of something
big 10 days ago that doesn't mean
anything saying hey something's coming
watch out something big what are they
supposed to what are they going to act
on that okay I guess we'll secure
something or what we'll look for
something big but people just lose their
minds and they I we we've had people on
this show where it's they just get
really really really angry at the
subject and start ranting about it and
I'm like what is up with people dude
certainly World War II the way Hitler
exterminated six million according to
historical records of Jewish people has
caused an emotional attachment to just
the entire concept of Judaism and
extermination of humanity so that's a
big part of it it's like never again
kind of mentality like I can't even go
there I can't even consider that and
it's like because it happened and and
honestly the Jewish population has been
for whatever reason persecuted
throughout history in different
countries I think in England they were
actually kicked out of the country by
one of the Kings of England at one point
just completely tossed out because of
their I don't know Bank what was it uh
it has to do with user and the fact they
allow user with it's a whole other thing
it's a whole other thing thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 800 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net